اكثر من 10 الاف عمليه اجهاض بشكل سري
وغير قانوني ادارها الجيش النيجيري منذ
عام 2013 في شمال شرق البلاد لنساء وفتيات
تعرضن للخطف والاغتصاب من قبل مسلحين
اسماويين متشددين
معهم بعيدا الى الادغال كنا هناك بين
ايديهم وتحت رحمتهم ثم جاء الجنود واخذونا
الى سكنتهم وهناك قاموا باجهاضنا
موافقه النساء وبعضها تم دون علمهن المسبق
باستخدام حبوب او حقن تحفزوا على الاجهاض
ثم وصفها لهن كادويه لتعزيز الصحه او
مكافحه الامراض والنساء اللواتي قاومن
اجراء اجهاض لهن تعرضنا للضرب او الاحتجاز
تحت تهديد السلاح او التخدير للاذعان
الحقنه التي حق بها ادت الى فقدان الحمل
لم يخبروني عن مفعولها ثم قالوا انه من
الافضل اجراء الاجهاض للتخلص من طفل جاء
من صلب بوك حرام
33 شهاده لامراه وفتاه وليست عاملين في
ميدان الصحه ولتسعه افراد امن متورطين في
البرنامج وعلى وثائق عسكريه وسجلات
مستشفيات لم يحدث ذلك مطلقا لم يحدث ولن
يحدث هذا الفعل ليس من شيمنا نحن عسكريون
محترفون وبشر ومن تتحدثون عنهن نساء
نيجيريات جميع وكالات الامم المتحده تعمل
هنا وبكل حريه ونحن نقدم لها كل الدعم
هناك شفافيه في نشاطها عمليات الاجهاض
محظوره في نيجيريا الا عندما تكون حياه
الام في خطر وتصل عقوبه انهاء الحمل
بطريقه غير قانونيه في شمال البلاد الى
عقوبه سجن تصل الى 14 عاما